I think he thought that you know kind of
his zelinski wasn't very popular there
was an awful lot of you know pro-russian
sentiment and whatever where he thinks
that is because people are Russian
speakers and that you know they're kind
of you know in polling they're you know
they're expressed Affinity with Russia I
mean certainly in Crimea
um that worked out because a majority of
the population had you know higher
Sentiments of feelings of affinity with
Russia and you know obviously you know
that that kind of they got traction
there but it's more complicated we
talked about donbass before about being
a you know kind of Melting Pot when you
know they tried the same thing in
donbass Donetsk and look hands because
it tried in Crimea in 2014 didn't kind
of pan out in fact you know a whole war
broke out they tried you know to kind of
in
um uh you know many of the major cities
in an hour under attack including Odessa
to kind of ferment you know pro-russian
movements and the completely and Italy
fell apart so Putin was thinking and I'm
pretty sure based on polling and the FSB
having infiltrated you know an awful lot
of the Ukrainian hierarchies we're now
seeing is quite apparent with some of
the dismissals in Ukraine he was pretty
sure that you know kind of he would get
traction and that it would be like 1956
in Hungary or 1968 in Czechoslovakia
remember he comes out of the andropov uh
Levy as it's called a kind of cohort of
people who come and under under the KGB
under Yuri and drop off and you're on
drop of has presided over a lot of these
anti-discident you know kind of
movements inside of Russia itself and
how you suppress opposition but also
over you know how you deal with
um you know kind of the uprisings in you
know Czechoslovakia and Hungary and
there's all these lessons from this that
you know you can put everything back in
the box and yeah there might be a bit of
violence and a bit of fighting but
ultimately you you think you've got the
political figures and you decapitate the
opposition the thought you've lit
zielinski would run away yarakovich ran
away but you know that was kind of a bit
of a sort of a different set of
circumstance responses and they thought
that all of the local governments would
you know kind of capitulate because they
had enough Russians and inverted commas
in there again mistaking language
and you know kind of positive Affinity
towards Russia for identity or how
people would react in the time and not
understanding people's
you know linkages and you know kind of
importance of place the way that people
feel about who they are in a certain set
of circumstances of place
but the invasion of Ukraine in 2022 is
unlike anything
that he was ever involved with so I
don't think he thought it would be you
know because it's kind of if he looks
back into the past you're right though
he wasn't involved in 68 or 56 or what
happened in the 1980s in Poland but
there's a very wide front and it's the
capital and I mean this isn't going for
this isn't chitchnail this isn't you
know kind of Syria or for example this
is a major Innovation exactly like a lot
it's large to the side it was more like
Afghanistan but they didn't realize that
because again ukrainians are us this is
kind of inability to think that people
might think differently and might want
something different and that 30 years of
Independence actually has an impact on
people and there's psychees and
if I look back to the 1990s I mean I
remember being in seminars in the target
at the time we were doing a lot of
research on
you know what was happening in you know
the former Soviet Union at the time
because the early 1990s just after the
you know the whole place fell apart
and there was already under Yelps in
this kind of idea of Russians abroad
Russians in the near abroad Russian
speakers and the need to bring them back
in
and I remember you know we had seminars
at the time where we talked about at
some point there'd be some people in
Russia that would actually believe that
those Russian speakers needed to be
brought back into Russia but that the
people who spoke Russian might have
moved on because they certainly had
other opportunities in other windows in
the world I mean look what's happened in
Scotland you know for example most
people in Scotland speak English
the Scottish language is not
the standard bearer of Scottish identity
there's just it's almost a civic
identity a different identity than not
just national identity just like you see
in Ukraine and there's lots of English
people that have moved to Scotland and
now think of themselves as Scottish or
Brazilians or Italians and you know all
kinds of people who've moved in there I
mean it's a smaller population obviously
it's not the scale of uh Ukraine but
you know people feel differently and
there's been a Devolution of power and
when brexit happened you know Scotland
didn't want to go along with that at all
and wanted to kind of still be you know
having a window on Europe and that's
kind of historic and lots of people in
Ukraine have lot West not East
you know it depends on where you are not
not just in
uh lavif you know or somewhere like that
but also in cave and and how to give you
know was kind of predominantly a
russian-speaking city but kharike was
also the center of Ukrainian culture and
Ukrainian literature you know different
points people have different views I
grew up in the north of England we don't
feel like the south of England there's
been a massive divide between north and
south and England for Millennia not just
centuries so you know people feel
differently depending on where they live
and you know kind of where they grew up
and Putin just
didn't see that she didn't see that well
hold on a second let me sort of push
back at the fact that I don't think any
of this is obvious so first of all
zolonski before the war was unpopular oh
it was what was it 38 something like
that but but best in the popularity yeah
let me uh sort of make the case that the
the calculation here
uh is is very difficult if you were to
pull
every citizen of Ukraine and ask them
what do you think happens if Russia
invades
just like actually each put each
individual Ukrainian in a one-on-one
meeting with Putin and say what do you
think happens
I honestly think most of them will say
that will agree
with a prediction that the government
would flee it would collapse and the the
country won't Unite
uh around the cause because of the
factions because of all the different
parties involved because of the
popularity might have said the same
thing about the Soviet Union when Hitler
invaded in 1941
you see the problem is Putin always
reads history from one perspective over
another I think most countries
basically rise to their own defense
so this is actually one of the first
times that Russia has been on the
offensive
rather than on the defensive
you know so there's kind of a bit of a
flip there
I mean obviously Afghanistan but you
know that was more complicated because
it was up but it was also supposed to be
an intervention right I mean it wasn't
supposed to be to Annex Afghanistan it
was to right try to you know prop up you
know kind of our reinstall of you know a
leader there
Syria you were in there to you know help
your guy Bashar al-assad you know turn
away the opposition chechnya was a
debacle the chechens fought back big
time and it was only by didn't of you
know a horrible violent persistence
and ruthlessness and nasty dirty tricks
that
um you know kind of Putin prevailed
there but and then you know he wondered
did he Prevail because what happened
you know sometimes describes the most
independent part of the Russian
Federation and ramazan khadirov and it
plays power games in Moscow yeah his
predecessors
um even his father and others wouldn't
have done that
and you know before that the dayaf and
mosgardev I mean they were willing to
make a compromise but you know they
wouldn't have had you know the same
position that uh khadira has had
so you know I think that again it's it's
your perspective and where you stand and
what which bit of History you start to
read and that's why I said that you know
kind of think Putin
it's again it's the information the word
that he processes it I think most
Russians also can't believe that they've
done something wrong in Ukraine I mean
maybe at this point things are changing
a bit but that's why there was you know
so much kind of support for this in a
right way I mean I have Russian friends
again I said but look what you know was
happening and done yet look what was um
you know the ukrainians were doing to
our guys
you know like what was happening to
Russian speakers
you know we were Defenders
we were not you know we're not Invaders
I think you know again the special
military operation you know idea now I
think it's flipping obviously in the way
that with the war going on there but
Putin wasn't you know kind of looking at
what would happen
I mean most of the kind of Glory parts
of Russian history when you kind of go
in you know you chase Napoleon back to
Paris or you chase the Germans back to
Berlin you put the flag above the
reichstag that's a very different set of
Affairs when you've been fighting a
defensive one you've been invaded from a
while where you invade someone else
and even the most fractured populations
like you had in the Soviet Union the
point rally round and you know World War
One the the fell apart I mean the Czar
didn't manage to Rally everybody around
withholding fell apart
and World War II Stalin had to you know
revive nationalism
including in the republics in Central
Asia and elsewhere to revive nationalism
and Ukraine suddenly found nationalism
you know in a kind of census that's
really interesting thing because it's
not it's not obvious especially what
ukrainians went through in the 1930s
it's not obvious that that I mean my
grandfather was Ukrainian and he was
proud to fight
a Ukrainian Jew he was proud to fight
and willing to die for his country it
wasn't like his country then was the
Soviet Union the Soviet Union right
sorry to clarify but he might fight now
for his country Ukraine yes but it I'm
just like uh lingering and the point you
made it was not obvious
that that United feeling would be there
no and again it wouldn't have been
obvious with the Soviet Union so yeah
that's what I'm saying sorry I was
referring to my grandfather the Soviet
Union we're both saying the exact same
thing yeah no yeah it's a really
powerful thing because I take it because
you take history as it happened
you don't realize it's gonna happen
differently it's kind of it's fast it's
that whole counter factual right yeah
yeah because I mean if you if you've
kind of that's that's why we all need in
the United States to really examine our
own history
because you know there's a lot of
lessons from that
but you know we we should treat very
cautiously it doesn't mean that you know
history repeats or even Rhymes you know
the old Axiom all the time but there are
a lot of things that you can take away
differently from
putting a different perspective in a
different slant on the same set of
events I mean I was used to wonder like
how many books can be written on the
French Revolution or even on the Russian
Revolution you know I studied with
Richard pipes I remember he was really
offended after he'd written his grip
microservice on the Russian Revolution
two volumes other people would you know
kind of write about the Russian
Revolution so I've written it all and I
thought well actually maybe you haven't
you know it's like there might be you
know some completely different angle
there that you haven't really thought of
and that's Putin you know I remember
peskov saying Putin reads history all
the time Russian history and I thought
well maybe she'd read some world history
you know maybe he should you know kind
of uh read some European authors on
Russian history not just you know
reading laminosa for you know Russian
um historians on Russian history because
you might see something from a very
different perspective and look in the
United States made a massive mistake in
Vietnam right
I mean there's so Vietnam is kind of
weak manipulated by you know kind of
external forces China's Soviet Union
but the Vietnamese fought for their own
country
they suddenly became Vietnamese and Ho
Chi Minh became you know gonna basically
a kind of a wartime fighter and leader
you know in a way that you know perhaps
people wouldn't have understood either